many Lebanese now use motorcycles
in the absence of a well-organized
public transport system and the rise in
global fuel prices it's the most
affordable way to get around
the sharp devaluation of the local
currency has made the situation worse a
tank of fuel costs more than the minimum
wage which used to be the equivalent of
450 dollars now it's not even worth
twenty dollars
basic necessities are Out Of Reach for
many especially since the nearly
bankrupt State lifted subsidies on food
and medicine last year
there is no work we try to sell whatever
we can so that we can eat and drink life
is unbearable
authorities blame Global inflation and
the Fallout from Russia's invasion of
Ukraine but Lebanon also has its own
problems
while we have an inflation Lebanon of
160 percent as per recent figures so you
have 90 percent related to the Lebanese
inflation while 10 percent may be
related to the worldwide inflation this
is mainly because of the collapse of the
Lebanese found we have been printing
later just to cover for the government
expenses the government is hoping to
increase revenues by hiking Customs
taxes but economists warn the decision
will cause a five to ten percent spike
in inflation in a country that relies
heavily on Imports
food prices have already increased by
700 percent since 2019.
Lebanon is one of the country's worst
affected by the rise in global food
prices according to the World Bank it is
second only to Zimbabwe
the situation has deteriorated so much
that the world food program says it is
planning to feed up to 2 million people
that's a third of the population
including one million refugees from
Syria other Aid agencies say they now
provide cash assistance instead of
focusing on development
a lot of families are not having two or
three meals per day anymore they're
having only one meal per day to be able
to afford this one meal per day they
have to sacrifice all the rest it means
they cannot access health care an
estimated 15 to 30 percent of families
receive help from relatives abroad
nearly seven billion dollars entered the
country this year but this does little
to address a crisis that has already
made four out of every five Lebanese
poor Beirut